how did that roasting feel
pretty tough but you know I think I a
little bit deserved it in that sense and
I hope people felt the peace they wanted
to feel and yeah I really did feel like
you know I'm gonna take one day at a
time I'm gonna move forward and it was
really difficult of course what's your
journey been like what was the moment
when you watched yourself or watched or
heard from people where you were like oh
my God I didn't you know what was that
that realization I think there was a lot
of in between like a part of me I was
like Hey like I'm a very blunt person I
have no filter in my brain and a part of
me like loves it I love that personality
the side of my personality that's like
that but at the same time I heard a lot
of people doing that and this is the
first time that I've hurt people I just
think in the in the past I brushed it
off so seeing it again and seeing like
the impact it made on other people and
how it hurt not only the people that I
was around but you know people in the
world that have been bullied and heard
and it was crazy because there was not
just like one thing I did wrong you know
it was just like things with the girls I
do want to say this I've never
intentionally laughed at anyone I'm
always laughing at myself I love
laughing at myself I'm always laughing
at myself and there's situations where
things are happening and um they're not
what they look like but again I
apologize to everyone and I'm just
excited to keep moving forward forward
and taking a day at a time and I just
want to continue to be the best version
of myself I think I'm still figuring out
who I am like how can I still be me and
still you know be blunt and open person
but kind of like be careful and cautious
of the people around me because I don't
want to hurt people like I remember
calling people from you know the show
and love is mine being like am I that
person am I this like horror like am I
this like evil Wicked person like I know
that I'm not I know that I love people
and that was you know the worst part of
me was on the show and yeah I just want
to continue to move forward was there a
bit of drama that you weren't involved
in tonight that you raised your eyebrows
you were like oh man you did you didn't
see combat I think there was a moment I
didn't show but I was literally crying
when Micah was talking because I was in
this moment where I said you know what
I'm just like a little sad for everyone
because I said like we are human every
single person out there sitting in those
chairs is human and only trying to do
their best and so like it just hurt I
felt like I was getting attacked a lot
Mike it was just everyone was it was it
hurt and I felt like what made me sad is
I feel like people wanted to see that
people wanted to see me her and laughed
at and same with everybody else and I
just I don't know it was difficult to
experience and I remember just sitting
there like kind of crying and I'm like
kind of bawling a little bit and I
didn't show it but I was just like dude
we're all just human we're all just
humans like trying to get through this
life like one day at a time there were
obviously accusations tonight that
people were not on the show to find
relationships but to find Fame for the
record once and for all did you go to
the show to find a relationship or to
find fans I think of course to find love
but I think like I know I it was so hard
because I had been asked this question
like why did you go on the show why'd
you go on the show and I kept asking
myself like Arena why did you and I
think for me I was like I want to see
what's like what could happen like of
course it would be insane absolutely
insane if I were able to meet my future
husband and get married on the show like
that was the ultimate goal but I also
wasn't completely stuck on that in the
sense of like hey if I don't meet him
that's okay like there's other fish in
the sea I'm gonna get opportunities but
I think for me it was like I want to
take some opportunity and do whatever
like experience and to the fullest you
know and whatever that was gonna look
like and it didn't work out for me and
it worked out for a lot of other people
and I'm really happy for those people
and I hope that one day I get to meet
somebody you know that I can spend my
life with where are we on that have you
met anybody have you have you considered
dating in this in this past year or do
you feel like you've had other things to
focus on um I definitely think at first
I was like whoa ready to get back out
there but honestly no I just want to
work on myself and I feel like I'm in
this area in my life where there's so
much changing gear shifting and I'm just
like you know what like I just need to
do me right now I weirdly felt a lot of
Peace because I was like you know what
at the end of the day and I know I keep
saying this but this is just TV dude
this is just entertainment and yes
there's people's lives and people got
married and I will fully respect that
but this isn't to find my life and it
will not and no matter how much people
try to accuse me or say that like I'm
gonna keep waking up and keep brushing
my teeth and keep doing the best I can
every day to be the best version of
myself and so I really did have kind of
peace I was like you know what like I'm
gonna be okay like my parents love me my
my family loves me I have I have I wake
up in the morning I have breath in my
lungs and I'm thankful for that
foreign
okay